what's up everybody this is Dave Pelz I
always had music I don't have music I
need to add music I used to have one and
then I was too lazy to figure out how to
like get the rights to it so I just draw
so it's great it's really great so hi
I'm Kate Quigley this is Dave fails as
you guys know and today is fantastic
because a it's two girls I love and I
have this girls I know I love girl
episodes and yeah you are so [ __ ] fun
I love the first time I tell you I was
like that [ __ ] is funny we've never
really gotten to like hang out I see you
around at comedies close online though
we're online pals is almost like real
friends it feels that way but anyways
you guys may know her from Last Comic
Standing you can see her on acting out
on MTV I feel like I've seen you on a
million things I feel like I've seen you
on like weren't you on like the Oprah
network or something I feel like it was
a few times but not on camera long and
everyone and be like oh maybe I just
maybe it's just because I follow you so
closely on social media like stalking
I'm like now she's on that she's
everywhere I'm guessing that wasn't your
birth name no the reason is so gay and
it's actually gay I was doing a lot of
shows in Orange County when I first
moved to California and I had a lot of
gay guys out there no see say you were
fabulous and I kept hearing it and my
real name beautiful love you mom and dad
but no one could smell it remember it or
pronounce it it is hard to because when
I looked up your name online I was like
I came in and I was like what do you
want me to call you typically and how do
you say this yeah it's really a
Jacqueline sham penny very pretty but
nobody could say it and then they're
like well how about you go buy champagne
I'm like well my name is not champagne
and Ripper you know not in public
yeah
I really dig it though it's easy to
remember as you are and you do have that
like the first time I saw yours like
this girl is fabulous I'm like oh [ __ ]
that's her name welcome so first of all
we have I mean we have mutual friends
and so many yeah so many and everybody
always tells me how cool you are and I'm
always like I got to get this girl out
for a drink or something I should have
brought alcohol in the middle of the bay
that'd be great
it would be fantastic the other day I
drink anyway when I'm at home so I
sometimes do yeah I have been the last
actually this is embarrassing but I have
been the last couple of days because you
know when you have a night where you
kind of get a little - I get a little
too buzzed I had a little too much to
drink and so the next two days ago I had
to chase the dragon cuz I'm so hungover
and I do days though what the hell are
you doing I went to a crazy I went to
our like a wild party yeah I don't do
that very often but I went to one of
those like kind of exclusive like
Hollywood like mansion party yeah and I
mean I was it was crazy it was like
something straight out of a movie it was
all like models and guys and tuxedos and
like free champagne and I feel so out of
place that these things really yeah cuz
I'm from Ohio and I'm like usually in
like flannels so when I have to like
when they say like evening wear I don't
even know what to do I start calling
everyone I'm like - like you look like
you would have evening we're ready to go
I borrow from my girlfriends I'm good
thing a lot I'm gonna girlfriends are my
size though I don't buy it so they don't
get worn much yeah what will melt with
Instagram and everything now we know
what's annoying and is happening here -
you got any makeup ready everywhere all
the time
and I'm so [ __ ] tired of that thank
you I could not agree more like just to
go to Ralph's I feel like you never know
who you're gonna run into and I bump
into guys when I've been at Ralph's in
nothing and they look at me like oh you
okay I'm like yes it's Wednesday and I
need some goddamn you know I think
you're sad
yeah like did someone just break up with
you you're like I'm buying eggs [ __ ] you
I feel that way too like I remember when
I first moved to LA the amount of makeup
that I owned could fit in a ziploc
bang I didn't wear makeup I'd never dyed
my hair I just wasn't that girl and then
I moved here and it's just you slowly
start to feel all this pressure because
everyone is just everyone in show
business at least looks so good all the
time and longer you do it the more you
find you gravitate towards people who
are successful and they were working all
the time and you aspire to be them right
my close girlfriends are so I mean the
bathroom is makeup wigs heal and I'm
like how do you understand so I guess I
get invited somewhere I'm like I don't
have gotta go to Nordstrom like girl you
ain't gotta go nowhere go in the
bathroom whatever you need I got I love
that but it's a lot of pressure because
now if I don't press up all the time
when I hang out with them they're like
what are you doing
I'm like I'm wearing jeans you can wear
jeans in heels like no you need a dress
go get miss banks are you spanks or do
you do the Spanx thing if I'm gonna be
on camera and I'm doing a show where I'm
a headliner I might wear other way now
it's got to be hot to be honest I don't
and it's not just because I'm not a it's
because not just cuz I'm small but like
I hate anything that's uncomfortable and
hot so anything I have a layer of heat
I'm like I hate it you know how many
girls I've seen your size and I see
their underwear and they're all wearing
Spanx are you serious this makes you
feel secure like a hug from your dad
that makes me feel not secure my dad oh
[ __ ] I forgot okay wait I just have to
make a public service announcement
really quickly my dad called me really
upset a few weeks ago because I talked
about him on the podcast and I always
make jokes about my dad because I have
daddy issues and I am kind of [ __ ] up
when it comes to guys and I make jokes
that it's all my dad's fault
and my dad listened to the podcast and
called me I've got a fight we got in a
fight because I always tell him not to
listen to my stuff because it's personal
stuff and then we got in a fight and I
blocked him I blocked him on everything
on Twitter and face I won't ever talk
about you and then we can move on with
our life what kind of did I was like I
was like dad I just talk about my
reality the way I remember it I can't
help it if I remember it different yeah
and you
remembered it but so I blocked him on
everything and then this is their this
is really sad and then like a week ago
he had to go to in the hospital or
something and he called me from the
hospital and he was like can you just
unblock me on your social media cuz I
really miss following you and so of
course the situation to get unblocked
so it's not sad it's actually my dad is
like a mad genius when it comes to like
emotional manipulation they found a lump
not knowing the lump was only a [ __ ]
hemorrhoid the bad news is apparently
hemorrhoids running my family so no you
know my dad gets them a lot too but I
always imagine I gotta be up there in
the age range for it to happen I think
you do and I think guys are more prone I
hope but I do have hemorrhoid cream in
my bathroom because I'm here is what I
hear the good for I've never tried him
for that I've heard that too yeah when I
hosted the AVN Awards my my friend Jenn
who did my makeup was like wrap your
stomach in saran wrap and a hemorrhoid
cream and it sucks all the moisture out
and you'll lose like an immediate three
pounds and it worked
yeah I was like super bloated I think it
was PMSing and I could barely fit into
the dress and then I did that for like
three hours and I fit into the dress it
really works so if you ever so white
right now I'm not putting on [ __ ]
cream and saran wrap it was about you
you had to see that what and it was my
first time hosting a big thing and I was
like nervous as [ __ ] and I wanted to
look perfect and like now if I had it to
do again I just I'd probably just change
dresses but uh so wait where are you
from I know nothing Bronx New York Oh
cause baby when did you move here in
2000 I moved here I moved here from the
Braun
Orange County complete like you know the
crack capital of the world - Orange
County of Beach City Orange County Costa
Mesa sanim a Santa Ana County nice okay
cuz there's a difference like people
here Orange County from other parts the
country and they just think beaches but
there's definitely like ya know parts of
Orange County that are definitely oh how
was South Coast Plaza Oh God Orange
County that's totally I love that so
that was a been a culture shock for all
but I come from I'm from every city has
their ghetto II area uh-huh and I'm from
the suburban mother and father
working-class part of the Bronx I swear
to God I thought you were gonna say but
the thing is I come from money come from
immigrants who work hard and I never
needed anything so if you like I came
from money that was never I don't know
poverty I'm a poverty now I didn't know
my mother now you do stand up you're
like oh poverty I know what that is you
put you gonna pose to be me laughing oh
you said that somebody said to you I'm
so proud of you you said like you've
made it you're probably doing really
well
but you're trying to figure out whether
or not they're produce at the 99-cent
store with its so that's the thing about
show business that's so funny is like I
have a roommate Eric Myers do you know
Eric yes very funny guy so Eric is you
know on Andrew Dice clays blue comedy
special on Showtime and I have the AVN
Awards on Showtime okay and we're
sitting at my apartment one day and he's
like how the how the AVN Awards turn out
I go I don't know I never saw it I don't
I can't afford Showtime I've never seen
my thing either cuz I can't afford
Showtime exactly on Showtime and we
can't afford Showtime that's the reality
of show business that people don't
understand I'll get friends out of here
have a show coming out and I'm like I'm
sure it'll be great cuz I'm never going
to see it let's go online no Stephen
Kramer Glickman used to host this
podcast okay and he he is one of the
voices in the new movie storks yeah it
just came out this weekend just came out
yeah yeah and so I go to him I can't
wait to see the movie I'm so excited I'm
so proud of you whatever and then it's
like that's great what are you gonna see
it
I don't know I was wondering if you have
like a press pass giving a free pass so
I made him take me to see his own movie
Wow
I feel like that's fair that's totally
you want me to support you this award me
that's the way that's the way so when
did you start doing stand-up 2005 oh
[ __ ] so what did you move here for I
moved here honestly I was in a
relationship with a guy for ten years in
New York we broke up like moved to
California to go to law school I applied
like I could only get into schools that
would way the [ __ ] away from the good
schools in New York oh really yeah but I
was so I was so ready for a change just
to move I moved to New York I got an
apartment a room and some old lady's
apartment in Orange County broke up with
him and I was actually glad to get rid
of him but I grew out of him I was like
I want to move I'm done ten years that's
a long time married that's a long time
he followed me out here if you did it
became like one life to live he's like I
love you I wouldn't I was going to marry
you we eloped in Vegas
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
this is very interesting so hold on you
broke up with him before you came here
yeah and then he follows like no he'll
know of course what you leave and then
like you were always the one duh
and he followed me out here that doesn't
happen to me but okay and then I
divorced him eight months later because
I was like this was a [ __ ] mistake
well I mean I don't know how you feel
about this but I feel most times when
you break up with someone once probably
yes we're not meant to be with them
because if it ends although I won't lie
there's many days that I wish that I
hadn't divorced my ex-husband
I had that feeling dude you do yeah
nobody's dead now Oh what oh my god
you're so fascinating he he was we
weren't together we weren't we were
divorce for five years I called his cell
phone
same guy same guy okay okay he we were
friends civil I called him we always
talked him the phone just kicked it I
called his cell to say hi and his
ex-girlfriend answered the phone of
course I'm like oh [ __ ] drama and she's
like no he was playing basketball he had
chest pains passed out he didn't make it
I'm like what do you mean he didn't make
it
he had a heart attack 41 athlete 6-4
hold of him in
ooh cuz man not only black man
have family history that they don't know
about you got to see what's going on
with your family and women yes heart is
no hurt is not a joke yeah yeah I'm so
sorry that's okay we were we were
talking about trying to be civil again
romantically well you weren't there yes
I was hurt but I wasn't like no it was
more like oh [ __ ] oh I'm like really
fascinated with this whole store okay
wait so he follows you out here you guys
start dating again eloping that was that
a spur-of-the-moment thing yeah well it
was bad it was planned but it was you
know we had rings made we had a dress
made out of suit man so the plan he
proposed yeah how did he propose he was
it was really like let's just want to do
it that's how it was
I'm very I'm not romantic when it's time
for a big thing I'm like I put more
emphasis on the small stuff are we gonna
stay together yeah you know - I'm like
we don't get along I gonna want to kill
you in your sleep more than I am the
[ __ ] drinking the champagne glass
I'm like you I need to like you before
we do any of that stuff I can honestly
say like people think I just say this to
like seem like a cool girl whatever I
don't care about the ring the proposal I
don't even really care about getting
married I just care about how the guy
treats me yeah when we're not in the
same room I can more about how a guy
treats me when we're not in the same
room cuz it's easy if you have chemistry
with someone you get along when you're
together that's the easy part right got
to be best friends that me and my ex we
were friends for three years before we
ever got romantic so that's why we
laughing we were best friends and I
think every woman there's gotta be a man
in line that you have my bone
you will never bone because that's how
you learn about men in my opinion you
want to be a man expert has some clue ya
have guy friends you do not want to [ __ ]
you'd ever [ __ ] you know you will
never [ __ ] I have a I have a lot of
those actually but I think I think that
most of them I if I got drunk enough I
might consider it that's every guy now
really bad enough to drink and we were
somewhere safe usually and this is I'm
gonna side like a total [ __ ] but I
don't care if we were if I was with
someone who let's say he was
and we were out of state and the drinks
got real I'm like you know what we're
not in California we're not it doesn't
count it doesn't count dude I went on a
military tour and my friend was like
whatever happens overseas doesn't count
and I was like I think it does I think
I'm pretty sure it does but here's the
thing I'm kind of fascinated by the fact
you guys were friends were so long
because I was best friends with my
ex-husband in command said we got
married super young I was 19 okay
he was older he was 24 okay but I had
known him since I was a freshman cuz his
little sister was my best friend
so like I we were always very close
friends and I think that's the reason it
lasted so long but it's also the reason
that like it's made it really hard to
move on like I've been single now for
four years yeah I still hold up every
guy and kind of compare the way they
treat me to the way that guy treated me
is we're such good friends I actually
wonder because of your post when you get
laid like you've made me very curious
about your personal life really because
you you don't you don't announce it but
you kind of alluded to it like I might
have it might be late and I'm my dress
might be torn but Matt TM eyeing us the
truth is that sometimes what I post is
like a hundred percent like really in
the moment what's happening yes
sometimes it's just something funny that
I think yeah I'm very good at making you
think that I happen
no but I'm funny that's it you're so
funny
you should follow Jackie fabulous yeah
you're so funny
I mean the truth is to be a hundred
percent honest about my love life which
I try to do on here and then I always
regret like I have a tendency to always
be very very hung up on one person for
long periods of time but it's usually
someone who's not very good for me like
I admit I'm very attracted to like the
bad boy with a sweet side and those are
not good relationship you are the white
blonde version of me are you the same
you love bad boys not necessarily bad
but the ones who are really nice dry me
up yes that's the prize here's the thing
I hope he doesn't watch this for like
I've been seeing a guy who is just on
paper a hundred percent perfect yes he
is so nice he's treating me with respect
he spends money on me he's handsome he's
successful he is honey he's funny he's
funny but he's not he is I can tell he's
not trying to be funny because I'm a
comic and he's totally cool with like he
has nothing to do with entertainment
he doesn't need attention God the more
I'm talking about more like why am I not
like but the problem is for some reason
because there's no like you know why
because you're not saying to me right
now this list you're not saying but you
don't have a but like he's so on so on
so on so on songs on great the but is I
don't have the impulse when I get drunk
to text him to send him dirty photo the
last day we can stop his podcast right
now if you're drunk and you don't text I
have sent my crotch thinking I hope to
god we never have a fallout where he's
like I have your crotch [ __ ] but my
thing is if my face is that crotch yeah
dude you know what though we haven't
hooked up yet that's the thing so like
but still sometimes there have been guys
that I have so much chemistry with I'll
start kind of flirty sending them like
the hot but not naked but like maybe hot
photos before we ever hook up and with
this guy I just maybe it's cuz he's so
great that I don't want to let him see
like my freak cuz I'm afraid he'll be
like oh [ __ ] you know he's that you were
a good girl I thought you were classy I
mean I don't think he thinks that cuz he
follows me on Facebook we're not Rocchi
yeah I try not to be yeah I pulled it
back a lot to avoid the cursing full-out
thee if I say I won't say dick out
allude to find funny words but I don't
really do the body parts anymore online
because you know careers are broken this
way I mean I it's weird I'm a lot
dirtier on Twitter then I am unfair okay
keep it cleaner although on my Facebook
fan page and I'll post whatever but
unlike my friend page for so many things
like my family's on there I feel
it has to be slightly today I posted the
word fog on there and I almost took it
down and that was like I hope they're
not weirded out that I said but like I
made a post today there's a guy that I
am so crazy about but as much as I'm
crazy about him I also hate so many
things about him it's an equal love hate
and the more he drives me insane and the
more I want to kill him the more I want
to [ __ ] him yep like in the moment I
will literally be talking to a friend
and be like I just want to get like I
wanna kit like he's a [ __ ] like I
don't get why he doesn't get it and in
that moment I'm like you know why I'm
gonna text him see if he wants to [ __ ]
tonight I can't
I am Wow
I have a girlfriend who just met a guy
and she's telling me how wonderful he is
and but I'm like when you sit in the
cloud with him and he's driving he look
over him and go mmm
that feeling like if you could pull over
right now yeah I would put the chair
back and sit on your face if you don't
feel that but she's like he's a goofy
guy and she's like I need the goofy I've
had too much of the bad boy
I made the goofy guy and I'm like but if
you are not attracted to him it's not
going to last but she is so and cheese
so in need of the goofy guy I'm like go
ahead girl try and do this guy but I can
see in her eye she's like still wanna
fight the other dude cuz I cuz I a few
weeks ago I had a gig out of town okay
and a friend came to visit me because I
was in the hotel and he was like sure he
came in visiting me and oh my god yeah
guy and it was he we talked for a little
while he [ __ ] me cross-eyed mmm and he
left now of course that's what I'm like
when am I gonna see him again but I
shouldn't because we are not meant to be
together we tried to date once you
didn't work they don't trust him I have
no proof I shouldn't trust him you know
I don't your gut you're like I can't
trust this I hope you're wrong but yeah
but I know you're not good for me why
did he leave and why did he leave what
do you mean well you said he [ __ ] you
and then he left you just mean he that
was that was the service call I was like
okay you know we gotta roll okay his
pre-show gotta katakana [ __ ] Wow it was
wonderful yeah I mean he's like you guys
have great sex yes you have a context
for you like you know what I'm good for
about three week
like that kind of sex where I'm like I
can go back to work isn't that wonderful
where you could get your mind back on
important [ __ ] cuz you've been [ __ ]
you can move on I literally the last guy
I hooked up with I turned to him and
said you just [ __ ] every thought out
of my head i guys guys say right this is
so funny guys say that right after they
come yeah there's this moment of clarity
actually because for like a minute if
they're not thinking about trying to
[ __ ] like the only moment in their life
and after the last time I hooked up I
felt like it was the closest I've ever
come to like I mean I'm still kind of
feeling it because it wasn't long ago I
can if it was maybe the best sex I've
ever had in my life this guy goes on my
list it's not the best he's top three
I've ever had no okay can we talk about
what about him made it cuz guys will
always ask this like what about it made
it he made it oh good about me and this
is me and this is self-centered
self-absorbed I don't I can't apologize
enough but I need it to be about me
because you make it about me I'm gonna
retaliate or separation right you're
gonna get what you need to get from me
but it has to be about me to begin with
ohand rude person so he made it about me
at least six or seven I swear eight nine
times and and then I was like after a
while I'm like okay I feel guilty can I
please give you something and I did
anybody he maybe watch it twice for him
but for me he got off easy go maniac
he's a macho ego dude the best guys in
bed are you gonna yeah yeah cuz only
wanted to take care about pleasing you
he gets off on watching me lose my
complete [ __ ] and the number of guy that
had in the last ten years who do not
give a [ __ ] or they think I have a huge
dick what else do you want I'm like you
need to do something I don't know this I
don't where if you hand in a math test
we're only the answers teacher will hand
you back the test and say you have to
show you work yeah that is what I feel
about men in dicks if you're in me you
don't get credit for a ten minutes
show your [ __ ] work no participation
award here is a first place only you're
totally right though cause like this is
the thing and this is important for you
guys who are listening yes if you make
it the first time you [ __ ] a girl if you
make it all about her and you make it
your mission to get her off in ways that
she's never had it before yeah that girl
will always hit you up again always
because there's so few guys that do that
and like when you find one like I tell
me if you're I'm sure this is true for
you yeah like I've dated complete
[ __ ] for months too long yes because
the sex was all about me and so
incredible that I was like I would I
would try to leave them and I'd go [ __ ]
someone else and be like oh he's nice
but I attacked this guy after doing some
other guy I've been like you still you
still move up there he's like you try we
shouldn't give them that power because
like this guy knows he has it over on me
100% and he is so confident that no
matter who else I [ __ ] they're not
even gonna come close they he doesn't
even here's enough to do anything else
anymore that's the problem you can't let
him know they're that good to come to my
wedding he'll be there in the wedding
party [ __ ] you know do you wonder when
it's that good between the two of you do
you wonder like sometimes I wonder like
I wonder for him if it's this good with
everyone cuz he's just so good in bed or
if this is a chemistry thing I do wonder
if he's a freak and just [ __ ] America
this way right but then I also know that
when we aren't doing it we have but we
do have a nice lead-up long
conversations right getting in between
the rest break we'll talk and laugh so
we are judge chemist friends you have
chemistry yeah yeah so that's why I'm
not like I got to figure out why I'm
like I like him if we never did it I
would still hang out with him because
he's a cool person he understands what I
do for a living I said I understand his
life yeah you know and he's a cool
person so that's why it's like
I don't feel like it's wrong I'm single
he's not married so I'm like well we
might as well enjoy it but I don't want
but I do make sure it have to enjoy
often because I will get hooked back
into feelings
look feelings and following him around
and [ __ ] camping out in his bushes
before front of his house stalking on
social media yes we should talk about
this I call reviewing and is calling
research review to see where you've been
we have to talk about that because I was
at a friend's house the other day a guy
friends and just a pal and we were
talking about he said so I've been
seeing this chick and she got pissed at
me the other day for liking some other
girls photos on Instagram that's
ridiculous
it's totally ridiculous I agree but he
goes how does she even know how does
guys and he like one pic or 76 pics
that's when they give it away well yeah
if you go here's the thing like so this
is gonna give away now I want to say I
don't do this anymore I've actually
gotten so good at not stalking if I'm
really into a guy I unfollowed him on
everything so that I can't see what he's
doing so that I don't go crazy cuz my
exes I'm like I don't want to know what
he's doing and follow I do it when I
like them because I don't want to give
myself because here's the problem let's
say that a guy that I'm seeing that I'm
super into let's just say he makes a
flirty comment on some girls page that
means nothing like I do that to guys all
the time then I don't want to read into
it and have it start something that
doesn't need to be started so I
unfollowed him but here's the thing I
used to be the girl that like let's say
a guy goes on your page and he likes
like three old photos that's a definite
he's flirting yes he wants old photos
like you know that was three months ago
exactly when guys do that it's so easy
to go on Instagram and look and see if
they did that to just you in that moment
or like seven girls at one time it's so
easy now because guys do they bail on
what sorry they they stay on Instagram
and just like just look at pictures for
hours man did I know who are with women
and the healthy relationship but they
still stay on Instagram because
Instagram is is porn without being porn
it really is
yes yeah like well I'm not cheating I'm
not gonna DM her I'm gonna look at she
has 89 pictures of almost areola I'm
gonna look at all of them dude I have a
hot super hot actor friend who is not
super famous but like on a TV show and
gets plenty of like dams right and his
uh he was showing me his DMS and he has
a girl and he's loyal which is amazing
because the DMZ girl sent him I'm just
like yeah like I see I get pissed like
these girls are straight-up just like I
want to just come suck your [ __ ] and I'm
like who is sending these I can I tell
you my last boyfriend he is very private
not on Facebook where he doesn't didn't
post me in him and I got it
cuz he told me so Jackie women don't
care and I'm like well I made my face
he's like they don't care so he said you
want to see my text I'm like can I
handle Eagles you got a promise you will
not start an argument you won't judge
I'm telling you these texts come in
whether I want them to or not I looked
at him what'd I tell you they were the
matheus most most aggressive team's
route at text messages well it's because
he's a grown man yeah works in the
business has for 25 years what business
show business show biz okay a music
business at one point got it so any him
and his friends have a history of dating
strippers okay so they're friends for
life there we regular girl with jobs so
the pictures he gets are like come and
get before I her head course and the
picture of her labia literally no way
and he's like I didn't respond back I
can't see the thing is we can't control
the minutia no cuz we lose our mind
because some of these [ __ ] and I
don't mean women I mean the [ __ ]
don't give a [ __ ]
that's so weird to me like that's my
thing is I'm trying to get better at
casual dating and trying to date like we
were talking about like how there's the
nice guy and then there's the guy that
[ __ ] you sideways and I'm like maybe
the best move is today both of those
guys to have the guy that [ __ ] you
sideways who by the way is the one
you'll catch feelings for it you can't
help yourself how will you come like
that I'm like maybe like my friend is a
pie-chart theory where there's
four pieces of a pie chart' there's like
the guy who's your best friend
the ego guy that just makes you feel
great about yourself the guy who [ __ ]
you sideways then the guy who's good at
tech the guy who can build [ __ ] can
change your oil guy but like she's like
I always try to have be dating a guy in
each section of the pie chart I totally
agree you do if you because you caught
me now I agree if you caught me 10 years
ago I'd have been like no I'm looking
for love now I'm like I'm totally down
to be a [ __ ] not a real [ __ ] but I
mean I paid I paid several dudes because
I get feelings all the time with every
guy if you are listening when you hear
this you and I hooked up I don't care
what you do for a living if it was one
time
I had a feeling for you during the time
your apartment I am Oh an emotional
basket case so I'm better off we're
having a variety yeah that way I don't
have time and plus I'm so focused now
and trying to get a TV show and we be
more real driven career driven so dick
for me now is just like I don't want to
get married if it happens it's great say
I want to get laid once in a while for
stress relief and for a financial that
love men and I want to get back to work
the love [ __ ] I don't think about it if
it happens it will be bi it'll be off my
arm by surprise off-chance you know I
feel the exact same way but the problem
is I feel that way but then when there's
a guy most guys try to relationship me I
don't know what it is about me but most
guys they just they try to lock it down
and when they're and I don't want that
cuz you're hot one and you don't you
don't seem like you give a [ __ ] man will
love that but the problem is when
there's one that doesn't try to lock me
down then I want him even though I don't
want him really no that's nature other
predators and if I flirt with a guy and
he that doesn't for a bag I'm like oh
you're gonna get it that's cuz you're
hot and you're flirty and you're cool
and you're saying and I'm mad and I'm
not worried about the rejection I'm like
I don't really want you why don't you
want me because here's the thing we're
comics
yeah we live and die like we are so used
to trying [ __ ] that doesn't work
I like that if we hit on you it doesn't
work like whatever new job get a new tag
don't come right back that's why we're
like mad no I hit on guys more than guys
hit on me all the time these guys some
most guys a guy for like oh here comes
Jackie I'm ready I'm coming for you so
wait so after the 10 year guy yeah then
you have you been single ever since I
have I've had if I were to be honest
I've had three real boyfriend's in my
life he was the one for over a decade of
my life I had one that I broke up with
over the holidays and we were on and off
for like four years in between him there
was a guy a military dude a crazy-ass
marine who was a bit of a dick but he
was amazing bad Marines Oh fantastic
they they brainwash you though they know
because they know brainwashing tactics
okay
the first time I [ __ ] this Marine
[ __ ] do it afterwards
he played a song he said to me he goes I
want you to hear this song kind of
reminds me of you and he played this
[ __ ] song and then every time I heard
that song for like six months we dated a
little and then he was one of those guys
and I get this all the time to that like
would come on super strong so you're the
best thing ever you're so amazing you're
so amazing and then I finally am like
fine I like you too and then the minute
I admit feelings they like pull back you
ghost out great but that [ __ ] did that
to me but then he brainwashed me with
the song and then it was like a hit
number one song on the radio I think of
[ __ ] that guy so good in bed if you
want to brainwash a girl after you [ __ ]
her like she can't think straight and in
that moment when she can't think
straight you play the song and the song
gets buried in a deep place but anyway
so only three boyfriends are there there
is a guy now but he lives in New York
known him since that was 18 okay we're
both in our 40s now I've always am NOT
good or it just he lives out there we
can't go on business because he doesn't
he's broke broke as hell Ben
forever he doesn't have any ambition he
has a regular job has had it for 15
years he's one of those guys back home
it's okay we're ambitious we're like I'm
getting a Tesla a year with that
sometimes I'm jealous of those people
those people that are just like I work
at 7-eleven and I'm happy if you're
gonna live anywhere in New York where
would you live he said well where I
could afford oh yeah was it what I was
asking you so where the [ __ ] would you
later you could afford money he really
doesn't care he wasn't give a [ __ ] I'm
like I'm trying to buy a complex in New
York and renting out your goals so he's
in New York and he the sex with him is
also phenomenal because I love him he's
one-to-one oh yeah but when I go home
and visit
I always hit him up I've always hit him
I mean when I was married dating I cheat
on everybody with this dude sorry no one
ever hears this my bad so when I go to
see him the problem with him is that he
makes love to me and it's great it's
great the third or fourth time cuz
they're used with you but when you first
get home you're like I need for you to
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of me
but he'll hold the back of my head and
he'll kiss me tender and I love it all
but he's such a once again I'm attracted
whenever I fall in love love is a big
guy yeah all muscle he can pick my big
like a little feminine ain't nothing
like a flower and we're like we're like
those were comics so we're in this dude
world so when somebody makes you feel
like a girl so when I see him he makes
sweet love and I'm just like if he
doesn't [ __ ] me soon I'm not gonna call
him again well then I would relax and
then I realized I do care about this guy
he actually cares about me are you
psychotic [ __ ] she actually loves you
yes he's making love cuz he loves you
and you're like can you just hurt like
choke me no he has nowhere to be I mean
I like guys the last a long time if it's
great but I'm just not into I'm cool
with some passionate lovemaking yeah in
the midst of
more ruff dominant yep [ __ ] in the
middle of it some and him and this is
another he doesn't have a computer he
doesn't care if I think he's handed too
big he can't type on phones he doesn't
care about that's a great guy to be with
though like I love to be with a guy
that's not on social me when my salary
gets a little more we can move him out
yeah okay cuz he doesn't know any the
cook he loves to cook a lot of reason to
love this great he's great but I'm after
a while I might get tired of coming home
he's always [ __ ] there unless you're
coming home and there's food and
massages what if you moved him here and
he basically was like you're kind of
like assistant and housekeeper and you
just paid all the bills and then he
[ __ ] you and did a cooking and the
laundry and the massage which is what he
is he's a domestic dude but he's very
masculine so that's perfect I know I got
to think about it though because I don't
want him but he's also a pothead a
problem but not a pothead yeah if you
smoke a little bit like I have friends
that smoke a little like right or relax
or anxiety but all day like I can't
function I'm like I can deal so mmm I
care about him but it's not but but he's
also good to the coach that can tell him
I need to you to just rough me up a
little bit hey he'll like he'll be like
you know I don't
and then he'll realize all right and
they'll get into it but it takes seven
[ __ ] sessions and two weeks of me
being in New York to visit my parents
rein to be like relaxed again I mean I
have a theory that guys that are really
sweet have a hard time being really
rough and aggressive we don't want you
because they could kill you if they went
too hard on you but do you think deep
down they all want to or do you think
some of them like my used to the day
when we were both under 25 and young he
was a bleep played ball all the time so
he being against the wall until I was
cross-eyed when older he got a guess and
he's at me surgery he's also aging
people get older and they're like Jackie
I'm not an athlete not really anymore I
can't do this [ __ ] anymore
I have to ask you because this is kind
of a new thing for me but and
this is personal whatever I get personal
wait it's personal now yeah I'll talk
about this on here but there's a guy
that I was hooking up with for a while
that liked to hurt me oh yeah this is
this is a detour yeah
like but I mean like I like a little get
hurt I can't you know like physically
like I like to be choked a little I do I
like to be choked and my hair pulled and
like I do all right I like guys that are
like they might kill you they might make
you [ __ ] you don't know I get it
breaker
yeah but this guy it really turned him
on to like leave marks on me like really
like bruises and [ __ ] right and so like
but the thing is I mean it kind of
obviously it worked for me like it
turned me on a lie but it also hold like
a [ __ ] like this guy would slap me so
hard that I would like there'd be like
coming and crying its ya ass die
anywhere with a little jiggle you know
your face no no I mean he would slap me
in the face but not hard enough to leave
a mark I don't mind the butt smacking
smacking and I find it like so hard
sometimes will you underestimate that he
you forget that we are the weaker sex
and Men [ __ ] is strong yeah I've had
I've had a guy just and I'm like it was
mark its tongue for days I was like I
like it but I'm not sure I want that
again not that hard it's fine in the
moment you try you sit you're like oh my
god I'm sorry
what do other people think when people
see me at the pool it was so
embarrassing
like this happened a we get him the pool
and I have to hamper breezes and I'm
like telling people I'm like well I was
out hiking and I slept I fell down the
hill
this is a rock I can relate
yeah because when you're in the bedroom
if you get off and as long as he doesn't
hurt you really really really yeah it's
nothing I would say hey stop that that
really hurts and you'd be like okay I'll
stop it then you don't get any more dick
I feel like god you're so fun you're
such a fun guy hey was this personal how
do you feel about anal I find a lot of
guys do not want to and I request it
they're like no oh you love it yeah I do
I tried it for the first time not too
long ago did you like it I did see I did
but this so taboo I don't understand why
it's just another hole yes I concur with
that oh well
have you seen Alan Lee Wang stand-up
special yet a new one okay what she
talks about about yes being afraid of
[ __ ] on the dead I think that's the real
reason girls don't want to do ain't know
it's happened to me and we both giggle
and kept it moving
yeah it's like my guy friend the other
day was like have you ever farted during
sex and every time and next question I'm
like everybody's gonna fart at some
point you're walking it's like pushing
air into yeah I like it I will say I
guess there are days that I'm like I
don't know if I want it today but here's
the thing I've been a mood I have to be
like you have to be like premenstrual
had a drink I'm like it's all let's go
for it yeah but it was a regular I'm
like now let's just do it regular I have
to be in a dirty dirty mood but you've
asked for it I've said no then would you
already have been like no are you
serious majority have been like because
either they're scared I'm they're gonna
like it some think it's gay some guys
are immature but it's the immaturity if
you don't like it you may be the end of
it but I'm like it's just another hole
it'll be twice as tight and I'm tight
I've never had kids
I'm 25 year old tight in there
I'm like you Shabbos my body is a
wonderland literally I mean the weird
thing is that since I let the guy do it
the first time he's never tried or asked
again I I kind of thought he was going
to last time when we had like the magic
sex yeah but he hasn't it
so I kind of think it's a conquering
thing that they just want to conquer it
yeah a lot of them just want to because
I did I have one guy friend who keeps
asking for it and we've hooked up
several times and I'm like we've been
you never we talked about it in taxi
like he gets off on texting about it
like when I get you I had a guy like
that that would always texts me all the
dirty shitty you forgot your outline to
his house the printout hanging above the
back
remember the [ __ ] you said you do get on
that and they get off on the discussion
and now I know I'm like I'm not doing
this he's like why cuz you don't do it
this is a build-up and when I see you in
word and then first we're talking I'm in
a no talking phase of life where I used
to be the girl who wanted the eight-hour
date the dinner the drinks afterwards to
walk on the beach another drink I'm like
you like me now talking men love talking
to me so that [ __ ] up my date yeah I'm
likeable but it means the [ __ ] takes
a long time to get to so now that I'm
older and I've had boyfriends and I'm
I'm busy and I'd rather go to sleep I'm
like well I'm a questionable I might
even be hungry cuz Cristobal I'm an
actor and a comic I'm home all day
I've eaten three or four or five six
times by the time 8 o'clock rolls around
you're good I'm good I'm the same girl
with you thank you I'm all about
cocktail yes if it's happening we hook
billing where you want to go eat I'm
like my bedroom I have go back my plate
is still in it I just ate you're like
actually I was hoping you would be
eating I'll be relaxing my bad yeah I
I'm with you on the bay turn I don't
even be that long with guys they wanna
they're not a comic or entertain
entertainment they want to know about
the business
I know that is a regular dude question
it is sweet when they when they want to
know a little but it's like they don't
understand it's like just like a plumber
would get tired of talking about his job
like if a plumber went on a date and the
whole time you were like so what's your
favorite kind of toilet what kind of
pipes are you what do you like people
don't do that with other jobs yeah
comedy or show business you know
so-and-so so-and-so and so-and-so now
here we go it is annoying it's like the
last thing I wanted to I mean I don't
mind talking about like a new bit I'm
working on or something if I'm into it
and it's someone who gets the business
but you don't want to have that combo no
not on a date
how about this do you hook up on the
first date then are you down I mean it
seems like it sounds like if you're into
them your toy down I don't I've never
had a one-night stand with a complete
stranger mm-hmm never
I'm always my thing is you got to be
able to find my body I don't want a
complete stranger
I want you have to be traceable somebody
has to know you from somewhere somehow
good to be Twitter verifying somebody
somebody something Kevin Bacon six
degrees something has to get back to you
yeah but I've never met a guy I didn't
be comfortable enough was a guy but like
you guys wanna get out of here no
[ __ ] I don't I don't know you
you know what nowhere I'm alone so if I
have a one-on-one not alone if I have a
first date hookup I know him already so
I don't feel that guilt of I don't even
know this guy I usually know him I get
it yeah we were friends
first from a friend through a friend so
I don't care about first date if I if
we're into each other yeah cuz I'm lucky
and I'm thinking I've never been
disrespected by a guy to a point where
I'm like oh my god I'm trashed now I'm
very lucky in that regard cos men treat
me nicely I have had the ghosting not
text me back then almost anything really
big had that happen to me oh you cuz you
read lady you really do like classy cuz
honestly like even when I first met you
and then I like saw your social media I
was like this girl's really classy she's
probably gonna think I'm like a giant
[ __ ] I was like when she sees me do
stand-up it's over she's gonna be like
this [ __ ] but you're totally like so
[ __ ] cool no I'm supportive of women
I'm like women we need to support each
other
and here's the thing - it's like I grew
up in a Christian household I grew up
going to church I grew up with very not
a conservative upbringing at all cuz my
my mom is very like liberal and supports
gay marriage and like everything like
that but I was raised like you only have
sex when you're in love like that's
always brought up and so it really took
me until my 30s to like be okay like
because in my head I always thought it
was real the guilt is real I get it
yeah and I'm finally just now getting in
a place where I'm like having fun and if
I meet someone who's cool and hot and
I'm like oh maybe I'll hook up with him
and we won't again I'm it took me to
this age in life to finally do that but
the other night I had my first ever
hookup with just a random dude at a
party I met this hot guy at a party the
drinks were flowing yeah and he was like
a soccer player body and the axe and
he's like Brazilian oh my god we were in
a bathroom and we hooked up party and
I've never done anything like that with
this done it with guys I'm dating yeah
yeah yeah but I've never done anything
like that with a stranger and then
you're dating a guy who are they there
in the bathroom nobody cares yeah nobody
yeah but then like afterwards the
funniest thing is I was kind of into him
but then afterwards he kept following me
around the party and talking by the end
of the night I found his personality to
be so annoying that he kept texting me
after the party and I just never
answered thank you I'm like I don't even
know your last name and that's the way I
want to kiss a ciated what are we doing
yeah but like first it's just funny that
that I'm in my 30s and I'm just finally
getting to that [ __ ] I know I lie though
I had one one-night stand it was it was
I was out out of town on a gig myself
met a guy in the elevator on the way up
to my bedroom my in the hotel and it had
a lounge in the hotel and he was going
to the loud and I we iContact played
pool from maybe half an hour did not
seem completely [ __ ] yeah and a few
drinks and up to the room and it was
great but I don't know why it was that
it was fun
fantastic but then he like rolls over
and fluff the pillow because he's going
to go to sleep all chipper chatty who's
leaving because I had a [ __ ] flight
as we do when we have them on the gigs
over ya know
did you sleep by the way did you get a
good sleep okay you know chatting we
exchange cells and this was fun but it
still wasn't what I was trying to do
yeah because I have this but don't you
want to talk but when I do when I do
treat guys as me they get offended do
you guys be like you don't want to talk
and I'm like no and then they're like
whoa I'll be back every disappear when
you turn it around and you treat guys
like check this out I went to a guy's
house the other night and same the same
guy that I had the sex with but I went
there and I got there and he was tired
and so I kind of like blade down with
them we started watching TV and he
started falling asleep and I said hey
I'm actually gonna go yeah but I get it
you're tired totally cool but I just I'm
not really in the mood to sleep next to
you and be sexually frustrated so I'm
gonna leave and he was like are you sure
he's like you drove over here I'm like I
know know me I'm definitely leaving huh
and then I got up a naked I got up naked
and started getting dressed and he was
like no no it wouldn't no wait you're
not you can't just leave you're not
leaving and we ended up hooking up and
then afterwards I was he was like -
still wanna go and I was like - he's
like no they don't want you to treat
them like me I think no don't they do no
they don't I'm gonna start trying to
treat them like me as a tactic and see
what happens just see what happens
you might freak him out I know I'm a guy
friend who said to me and he didn't he
never really reveal that he doesn't like
when a girl wants to
with him and he know that all they want
is that he doesn't it's a turn-off he
wants to he wants to he doesn't want you
to hit hit him up cuz you just wanna
[ __ ] and I'm like and he's a very he's a
very attractive guy beautiful penis see
single no okay so I'm like well then but
don't hang out with these girls if you
know that they have their mind on that
but he still wants the company so it's
it's but when you go for it
he's one of these guys who needs and
wants and likes the long date he's a
long day dude okay depending on the girl
if you were her if you and him are
friends it's gonna be a long-ass night
before you see is Nick the biggest prize
because he doesn't really meet or crave
sex I think anymore the way a girl does
the older guy gets first of all that
libido [ __ ] it drops
oh wow annoying well I'm just like I
don't want to do anything else but [ __ ]
thank you I've been talking about it on
this is a bit that I've been working on
on stage lately because it's I've been
talking about how when you hit your
mid-30s as a woman you just you want to
[ __ ] all the T it's crazy what happens
and then guys are just that's why you
got to go after like 22 year-olds ooh
because they are the only people that
want to [ __ ] like I'm had a lot I had
not I've had like three in the last two
years I don't want the number to sound
high but the last guy I did have just a
playful time with a decade younger than
me fantastic I mean so fantastic when he
came like bottles of semen so many
babies came out of his body
yeah right and we be finished we get
water I make one joke to heart again I'm
like oh God why this and when they hit
40 I have to tell you that I did I
hooked up with a guy who not I mean a
few months ago he was 28 and which for
me is young I said go for older guy yeah
he was 28 and we [ __ ] and it was
amazing it lasted forever it was so
great he was so great and then
afterwards like 10 minutes later he
starts trying again right and I so used
to order guys
was like forgot that guys can [ __ ] again
I can't see me out no hotel he this is
the thing everyone like one out of every
47 dudes not that I've had that I can be
over 35 and keep going this guy with
water maybe a half a break and back at
it so either you get you get lucky at
the older guy who was healthy or you get
the younger guy who you get reminded I
forgot and they can reboot because my
whole life into the boyfriend in my 20s
we will do it several times a day
morning nights yeah I'd be sore one time
we could visit so much I [ __ ] the skin
off his dick until they get it right
again
holy hell bloody hell here oh [ __ ] oh
you know you're doing a lot weight gets
so dry and you're not getting Lube I'm
not getting wet but you still to erasers
rubbing together but you want it so bad
you don't care those days over I'm just
ladies my favorite guys ever those days
are holy I I do have several friends who
are male porn stars from hosting the AVN
Awards and they take these herbal it's
like herbal cialis I don't know they
were they swear by them in their herbal
and there's no side I wish I knew the
name of them because for guys like in
their 40s it's like about to roofie oh
you wanna go seriously for cuz the last
few guys that I've been with have been
in their late thirties forties yeah I
mean it's good it's fun but it's a long
hair like I'm usually you're like and
they're like no are you crazy
yeah yeah 28 is the age this is my last
question for you like this once so fast
cuz you're hilarious when it's time to
talk about stuff honestly I realize
you know it's it's a it's a podcast
people will listen cuz you have a big
following Wow and they want to hear real
[ __ ] people want to hear real [ __ ] and
at the end of the day we have nothing to
be ashamed of or America we're growing
up this is human nature
yeah we're not [ __ ] were heterosexual
women yes see we're gay wouldn't matter
you look I'd be real I wish I have more
sex I don't have oh yeah I mean I don't
I make it sound like I have a lot on
here because I talk about every time I
get good we're taking a cumulative of
all the guys random party years and
putting him in one conversation it comes
out the two years since January I think
yeah there's been like two there's no
like two or three for me yeah here's a
question last question the show is
called date fails I ask all my guests
and I have to say that a scab on the
[ __ ] is pretty bad that might be a date
fail but Marion love in a heal we got we
got through it can you think of your
worst date or worst sex experience or
just any awful date that you had that
was a complete fail it could be anything
it has not had a really bad date in a
long time because there's always friend
Zoey yeah but I'm gonna be hooked hooked
up by a friend Cory back in the Bronx
his friend his friend showed up and when
this is when the Volkswagen Jetta was
the hot car to have the old hoopty one
not the cute ones now okay pick me up
any he had I got in his car he didn't
have his shoes on and he had one foot
out the window while he drove and he
smoked a cigarette and you never met me
why do you have no shoes on he was just
chillin
and I'm like so you're gonna give me the
barefoot and cigarette Oh on the first
date did you even go out there but I
didn't see him again after he and he's
calming like no interest you long I'm
like yes I lost I ate and then I lost
interest what was he thinking I just
think a lot of guys and this is a
California thing I've had I've had like
my last boyfriend respect them I love
you still you're my friend for life but
the casual thing in Cali kind of gets on
my nerves I don't my love casual it's
cool as hot middle of the day be casual
but on a date you've got to put some
[ __ ] effort into yeah especially the
first day first I need the impression
because you know if is hot and there's a
plan
chances are I have put in some serious
[ __ ] work
yeah I might just come back from the
mall because outfit I bought I just
[ __ ] bought yeah I probably just left
the nail salon and the hair place you
know and he has no idea that I've spent
all day getting this car done beforehand
they you know guys don't understand one
of my biggest [ __ ] pet peeves is if
you know you're gonna hook up yes you
shave your legs you take care of all
your business you wash your hair you
like get ready to hook up like even if a
guy booty calls me I make sure my [ __ ]
is correct I was right yeah there's
nothing that makes me more annoyed than
when I know I'm gonna [ __ ] and I get
ready for it and then the guy blows me
off or can't I get I'm like cuz guys
don't realize how much work it is for a
girl guys to just hop in the shower
maybe trim like a t-shirt out of the
dryer put it on and they leave they
don't get it the guy in New York I
killed no I'm coming home Thanksgiving
I'll have weeks notice I will get there
to his apartment and he's like I'm sorry
I didn't clean up a shower I'll go get
the sheets out of the dryer no mattress
I mean no she's on the mattress and I'm
like how many weeks have you known I was
crying I hope he's listening to this but
he's not have a computer you need to
call him next time I had a time and be
like you need have your [ __ ] correct
when I arrived I've never done that to
him because I please talk to him so
nicely do it I want to be like you know
I'm coming trying open the door in a
shower cuz you were just coming out the
shower because he leaves me in that
bedroom for hours while he gets prepared
while I'm there I'm like [ __ ] that
I get back in the moment it takes me so
long and not be pissed I would - no you
need to tell him that's your I'm gonna
tell you when I tell him I please - I
gave him a list you Colin I had to mail
it unfortunately he doesn't have a phone
or email him a letter
Jackie you are fabulous you've been such
an amazing guest plug anything you want
plug all your [ __ ] tell them what to do
what's the plug uh I'll be in Vegas
opening for Alonso boat
because while I am a headliner so gotta
bet on girls
hell yeah and Alonzo I opened for him
forever cuz he's amazing he's so fun
mentor fantastic we'll be at the
Tropicana last factory in Las Vegas
October 24 to the 30th and the shows
will be great because he and I together
are a really great mix and now that's
anything for now that other girl Jackie
fabulous calm my schedule was on there
and Instagram Twitter Facebook at Jackie
fabulous you will find me because I am
way online way more than I really want
to be now I love that and I have a lot
of people in Vegas so make sure you go
see yours yeah you guys are awesome
thank you as always for tuning in to
date bells I love you make sure you're
following me at Kate cue funny and we'll
see you next time bye dude